John Smoltz back here in the Rich Eisen
show re John I'm doing good rich thanks
for having me you bet you're the first
person I thought of when I heard about a
shortstop going down with Tommy John
surgery in Los Angeles and for a team
that if it wasn't for Charlie Morton in
Game seven last year might be the
defending world champs for the Dodgers
just so much going on with this story is
to the how and what and then the the
concept of you need to win when you have
the opportunity what was your first
thought when you heard that Corey Seager
needs Tommy John surgery yeah catchers
position players really have this kind
of issue it's unfortunate the guy's a
stud when the Dodgers are not clicking
and this doesn't bode well for them you
know I think in in the time that you
know when I first got my Tommy John
surgery and then the epidemic that has
existed to pitching and we've come down
to it so much so that people don't pay
attention to really how to better
prevent it's just almost like well
you're gonna get one let's get one get
it out of the way but I can't imagine
Pro position player what that must feel
like because that's the last thing you
think is gonna happen you so what was it
is it just two men too much extra swings
as the rumor is here in Los Angeles that
they they needed to tell this kid to
chill a little bit and back off what
what's your best call and how something
like this happens to a shortstop John
yeah I mean freakish genetics I mean
there's there's there's a an array of
things that come into play when you
think about a left-handed hitter and
even though swinging left-handed and
throwing right-handed you wouldn't think
swinging has anything to do with Tommy
John because it's an opposite motion and
it might have been one throw or a couple
or a combination of throws that tweaked
it and then you know that is the unknown
of position players catchers have to
throw as much as pitchers and that's
what people forget you know the ball
gets to them they got to throw it back
although be it not at 98 miles an hour
but
then they gotta come out firing and you
know I would I I would think that
swinging a bat left-handed it would have
to take an extreme amount of either
swings or something freakish to happen
so that that that is just a bad bad
break that hopefully you know he's able
to recover and at least he doesn't have
to get to a point well it's still a long
recovery it's just he doesn't have to
you know fire the baseball as many times
as the pitcher does so hopefully the
recovery is quicker and when the loss
last night in Arizona Dodgers were eight
back and I know there's still so much
time it's May first etc etc etc but what
what gives with the Dodgers this year so
far John well you know it's their
offense and Turner not being available
has has really showed that that is a
main cog not only in their offense but
it helps them click it's a presence
they're missing you know when I think
about the Dodgers and the depth that
they have and the pitching staff that
they have you know you come out a little
sluggish and we know their historic
stress they went on before I don't know
if that's capable again especially ever
in baseball but here's what I think
people don't realize as well the Dodgers
are still going to be ok when they share
our games but it's the much improved and
much more confident Diamondbacks that
they're gonna have to worry about
because you give that leash a little too
much room and I don't think the d-backs
are going to look back they're much
better last year having experienced the
postseason they got beat after the
wild-card round to the Dodgers they had
won 11th regular-season games at one
point between last year and this year
and their confidence of we're a really
good team and we are not relinquished in
this league lead grows every week they
have this kind of league lead against
there let's face it the Diamondbacks
have always been the little brothers of
the Dodgers so this is a huge deal and
even though there's a lot of baseball
season left you want to be in the
position that the backs brand knowing
you're a better team having gone through
last year even though you don't have JD
Martinez pitching staffs much better
the Dodgers still have plenty of time
but they're going to
to get healthy offensively john smoltz
here on the Rich Eisen show getting set
to call the Yankees and the Astros on
MLB Network tonight last night Charlie
Morton and the Astros cooled off the
Yanks and Astro the the Astros of 120
lost 10 you've got the Red Sox of 21
wins you've got the Yankees coming off
of that hot streak Otani if he can stay
healthy as opposed to be if he as he's
been the last couple weeks
you got the Angels Seattle doing well in
Cleveland perhaps not performing up to
what they are capable of doing who's the
best team in the American League it's
all said and done the best Eastern
Astros they're the best team to start
the season I don't think it'll change
much throughout the year
you know the unknown has injuries of
course that you can never predict but
this team has a pitching staff that's as
good as anybody you'll see in a long
time it has the dynamics of an offense
that really shouldn't go on any
prolonged prolong slumps and they've got
guys I've said this before I said
tonight on telecasts there's a team that
is one of the the World Series you can
look back and go okay six seven eight
guys had fantastic way above-average
years don't think they can duplicate
that I would say that the Astros only
have two or three guys that won't have
better years that that's the possibility
that they have going form so they add
Kohl he's a monster we've know you
talked about Charlie Morton Verlander is
probably one of those guys would be very
difficult to duplicate the run ease on
but they can all get better you know
Korea missed a bunch of games
Altuve maybe a guy that okay you know
it's hard to keep going up from what he
did but they have everything that you
need for a young team that's still
hungry that they know there's a
difference when you leave spring
training internally you guys may not
admit certain things and are equally so
but they know they're the best team in
the American League and there's a big
that's a big big that's a nice thing to
have going in knowing that you're not
going to go into prolonged slumps
because your starters one through five
if they stay healthy kids shut down the
opponent's that at a pretty good rate
and I love that take John you could even
include age
in there too right having a better year
even though he was stupendous last year
with the flood and the enemy and the
issues that were going on in the city
and what he did you could even include
him in that mix absolutely and I'll tell
you what he's done you know in this
sabermetric world that we kind of
sometimes pour too much in one bucket
but it's great to have the blend of
information and the astros do it as good
as anybody his ability to manage that
team and people this is just not only to
your point about you know the tragedy
that was taking place in Houston but the
ability to go with some gut feelings in
times where maybe it was unconventional
and he's bought himself some credibility
and those are those arenas now because I
said this last year say it again it's
nice to have ton of information it's
nice to have a pre kind of play game you
know game plan that if everything works
out the way it should it's great to have
that information but if you don't adjust
on the fly and if you don't let your
eyes see some things that are different
than the data that's being poured in
you're doing yourself a disservice and I
thought his managing skills in the in
the World Series especially were second
to none they were gutsy and it panned
out and well they were they ultimately
won the World Series I think because of
it so as a manager I always ask young
managers or new managers we're always
kind of looking at hey as a player what
do you want to work on this year what
would you like to get better what would
you like to improve on rarely do we ask
the manager that and that's my first
question every year early on and what
you learn from last year as a manager
what would you do differently and those
are questions that are intriguing to me
because we rarely focus on that aspect
of it because we're so consumed on what
a player can do better
last one for you John another reason why
I wanted to chat with you today on May
the 1st is because you and I have had
conversations lamenting this Yolo era
and Major League Baseball where
everybody takes hacks up they're like
you only live once and April became the
first month in Major League history in
which there were more strikeouts than
hits we had Josh hater last night is
very talented I mean he does look like
the Big Unit it's frightening
times when he's following through this
Milwaukee worse reliever who became the
first pitcher ever to record eight
strikeouts and fewer than three innings
I'm wondering where where this league
goes from here or if this is a problem
John Boehner all said and done
oh I ultimately think it's a problem
long-term I do and I think there are
other people's to be in powers that are
concerned about this and are looking at
it to make sure that whatever needs to
be done to create a different scenario
if you will and look every sport has
done it baseball has been the most
traditionally beloved historical sport
that is slow to change for a lot of
reasons but other sports make
significant rule changes to enhance
their sport to enhance excitement to get
the fans as into it as possible and I
think you're going to see that down the
road baseball has always had a way of
correcting itself of finding ways to
adapt and we're in that cycle right now
of not the ball being put in play much
dynamic pitching but too much pitching
meaning too many pitchers per game and
whether that becomes a rule change down
the road that's something I'd like to
see which allows pictures to still pitch
but not as many men inning pitching
changes that we're seeing at a historic
rate and you know that that that's one
way of looking at the game in a positive
way to create you know strategy as well
as you just can't keep making one batter
pitching changes or the amount of you
know we're averaging somewhere between 8
and 11 pitchers per team / I mean per 2
teams that's that's that's a big number
mm-hmm that's a lot of drag on the game
and the time that it takes to play so
it's a long-running question to say I
think that you're going to see down the
road some certain changes they may seem
insignificant in the beginning all
geared towards how do we find a way to
create the excitement that doesn't
become very stagnant I watched a game
the other day and by the ninth hitter
between the two teams was the first ball
put in play geez to start the game
so that means the starter struck out the
side in the first the next guy struck
out two or three and and and a couple
walks and you know so that that part of
it is definitely being looked at 8 p.m.
Eastern tonight Costas Verducci and you
John Smoltz I will be out there with my
kids watching I'll be pulling up a chair
you got it thanks you always thanks it's
John Smoltz MLB Network Fox Sports and
baseball hall-of-famer here on the Rich
Eisen show the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience